j'ai vu une augmentation une bonne
organisation de la violence au sein des
transports donc de façon récurrente de
plus en plus d'agression des
machinesistes l'agression de jeunes
femmes malheureusement les gens tournent
réagissent pas forcément voilà ce qu'il
faut retenir 122000 victimes dans les
transports en commun en 2021 ce qui nous
fait une moyenne de 338 victimes par
jour c'est 4% de plus que par rapport à
2020 c'est souvent des personnes
immigrées souvent clandestine même des
mêmes des mineurs clandestins isolés
jusqu'à 8 km de long certains attendent
près de 30 heures pour passer quelques
secondes seulement sans s'arrêter c'est
interdit devant la dépouille de la
souveraine et là sort son père et ses
deux frères et son père se jette
littéralement sur moi en me tenant des
propos
du style je vais te défoncer la gueule
sale [ __ ] de député RN à Mayotte une
situation inédite pour protester contre
les vagues de violence qui se
multiplient les élus ont décidé tout
simplement qui permet les écoles et les
administrations et ce jusqu'à nouvel
ordre car le département le plus pauvre
de France est toujours en proie à une
vague de violence affrontement entre
bonnes rivales attaque contre les
véhicules l'insécurité est désormais le
quotidien les habitants de Lille l'autre
frère qui au départ avait pris ma
défense quand les gendarmes étaient
présents il a couru jusque devant ma
maison en me disant je vais chercher mon
fusil chez moi et je vais te fumer ça
pue de député Elisabeth borne invente un
nouveau concept et consommer moins pour
payer plus parce que la réalité c'est
que la facture des Français va
s'alourdir que beaucoup de Français ont
déjà beaucoup de difficultés de pouvoir
d'achat que le gouvernement a refusé
toute augmentation significative du SMIC
veut dire quoi que on entre dans une
période de 100 et de larmes en fait pour
les pour les comités français c'est une
période de difficulté nous le savons le
prix de l'énergie le gaz et
l'électricité a été multipliée par 5
pour le gaz par dispo l'électricité sur
les marchés sur les marchés
d'approvisionnement si elle se chauffe
ces abscisses ménage se chauffe au fioul
il aura en plus une exceptionnel parce
qu'il se chauffe au fioul parce que
c'est ce que le Parlement a décidé cet
été avec cette enveloppe de 230 millions
d'euros de 100 à 200 euros également
donc au global on va dire pour les
ménages les plus modestes ça fait
jusqu'à 400 euros d'aide exceptionnelle
cet hiver pour remplir SAQ sensuel avec
la victoire officielle aux élections de
la coalition de la droite et de
l'extrême droite le succès est court
mais suffisant pour former un nouveau
gouvernement autour du leader
conservateur ou le christersson la
gauche elle perd le pouvoir après huit
ans aux commandes du pays moi je vous
dis qu'on a un droit à l'appareil je
vous dis qu'on a un droit à la
transition de des métiers c'est à dire
que quand on a un métier dans une
industrie polluante et bien on a le
droit à changer on a le droit aussi de
faire des pauses dans sa vie et surtout
il nous faut retrouver du temps le sens
du partage et la semaine de quatre jours
comment une fillette de trois ans
a-t-elle pu être oubliée pendant 8
heures dans un car scolaire ni le
chauffeur ni l'accompagnatrice ni
l'école n'ont donné l'alerte est-ce que
ça nous mène pas la guerre des sexes
c'est-à-dire que moi si je vois mon mari
en train de manger de la viande je vais
lui dire tu es en train de tuer la
planète je crois que vous me posez cette
question de garder ça que à chaque fois
que je viens vous voir et je vous
rassure à chaque fois je manifestement
je n'ai pas réussi je vous le dis je
vous pose des faits sociologiques si on
veut faire bouger notre société et on a
eu un été cataclysmique on a eu un été
cataclysmique les incendies repartent en
Gironde si on veut bouger les choses il
faut appuyer sur les choses qui sont
impensées dans notre société il est
minuit 26 quand soudain c'est le drame
il faut bien regarder en bas de l'écran
non je te crois pas et la visite
surprise n'aura duré que quelques heures
avant qu'il ne rentre à Kiev hier soir
mais tout ne s'est pas passé comme prévu
le président Zelinski a une accident de
voiture percutée par un automobiliste et
je parlerai plus de garder sexe